Peter Brown here at the game spot news  update Ubisoft has confirmed that the  division will not meet its 2014 release  date during a post-earnings financial  call Ubisoft announced that the  post-apocalyptic shooter coming for xbox  one playstation 4 and PC will now arrive  sometime in 2015 revealed at e3 last  year the division is a third-person  shooter set in New York after disease or  something ravages the population Ubisoft  has said the title will feature an  unprecedented level of realism no  details or reasons for the delay were  provided but the Ubisoft CEO said the  publisher will share more details about  the game during its e3 media briefing  next month III is less than a month away  gamespot will be there to bring you all  the hottie 3 news about division and  other next-gen titles